[Music]
welcome back hot ones fans this is Sean
Evans and it's that time it is time to
introduce you to the Season 22 hot Ones
hot sauce lineup as always we have a
collection of Indie sauce makers who not
only make delicious hot sauces but are
also an amazing tight-knit group of
people and on that note in Wake of the
devastating wildfires in Maui Hawaii
last month multi-season hot ones Alum
adobo Loco sprung into action donating
proceeds from the sauce to help
residents in need that right there is
what the hot sauce Community is all
about so I want to give a shout out to
adobo Loco and of course rescue efforts
are ongoing so if you're interested or
you can help support please see the link
below me in the description of this
video and with that it's time to
introduce you to my 10 new best friends
the Season 22 lineup and we begin with a
historic moment in hot ones history our
first ever buffalo sauce we knew that if
we were going to make a buffalo sauce it
had to be something truly special and
something that would get the seal of
approval from our own buffalonian camer
guy Bill it's mild it's Tangy it's made
with age cayenne and real butter that's
right you heard me right no melting no
mixing required it's all right here in
the sauce and we present it to the
pantheon of great Buffalo sauces in the
history salute to the OG's of Buffalo
grab a bottle let us know what you think
and now it's time to move on to Sauce
number two in the number two spot our
friends at angry goat and Vermont are
back with a sauce that brings the crispy
charred flavor of blistered shashido
peppers and blends it with Savory garlic
whenever you order shashido Peppers at a
restaurant they're always those random
ones that are extra spicy so in the the
number two sauce you can expect the
unexpected with this one you never know
what you're going to get all right
moving on to Sauce number three
introducing a brand new member of the
hot ones family Pisa here in the number
three spot the flavor profile is
inspired by founder and maker Marita
Bru's Dominican Roots Caribbean grown
passion fruit is the star of the show
but then you have this chilly heat that
rounds out the whole tropical three-
spot experience and then moving on to
Sauce number four summer may be behind
us but it ushers in a season of
tailgating so the official sauce of
Grilling and Chilling takes over number
four if it's anything like last year
those deep Smoky notes of Chipotle may
be all that can comfort me through
another Bears season but not this time
around baby it is going to be the taste
of Victory all season long the Bears
going all the way and fueling me through
it all hot ones barbacoa all right
moving on to Sauce number five and what
I have to say in all of my years of
doing this show just my favorite sauce
to look at through the glass bottle it's
absolutely gorgeous like a work of art
like the surface of Jupiter say hello
number five
Diablo the Diablo power jab delivers a p
p punch to the face of serrano peppers
tied chili flakes and dried scorpion
peppers plus powerful Filipino flavors
with aromatics like ginger and garlic
they all come together to make a sauce
that tastes just as good as it looks and
with this one that's saying
something you guys picking that
up did Dave Gro just walk back in the
studio I'm catching hints of
whiskey oh you know what that's actually
just our sauce to kick off the back half
at number six we have a whiskey infused
hot sauce in at number six is whiskey
smoke ghost the brainchild of Sarah
Marshall who showcases her dedication to
craft ingredients it's a sweet and Smoky
sauce featuring whiskey white balsamic
date syrup and yeah of course ghost
pepper to really kick up the heat here
to kick things off in the back half and
then moving on to number seven another
familiar face with ginger goat Ginger
goat's Tropic star lights up your taste
buds with tar mango citrusy lemongrass
and the subtle sweetness of star anise
shout out to our Pals at Ginger goat a
legend of the hot one season 15 lineup
and Prime to achieve their own version
of goat status with a return to the
table here in Season 22 and speaking of
sauces that make the return again and
again and again and again and again and
again again again again again again the
bomb at number eight if there's one
thing that you can count on in a forever
changing and uncertain world it's that
the bomb will hold on to its eighth spot
and here it is in Season 22 once again
de bomb Beyond insanity and then
following that up in the wake of the
Fallout from bomb we have Dawson's
another familiar face to
Encore it's never easy to follow the
bomb but zuu seven pot from Dawson's
does its damnedest the seven pot peppers
in this sauce just provide a head
banging heat a beautiful color but do
not be confused an absolutely brutal hot
sauce and moving on to number 10 it's a
historic lineup here in Season 22 and
we're bookending with two brand new hot
sauces say hello to the last dab
experience Behold The Experience they
said it couldn't be done perhaps it
shouldn't have been done but we've
raised the peak of Mount Scoville to
towering New Heights thanks to smok and
Ed Curry's diabolical minations Ed's
worked his magic to distill the power of
pepper X into a brand new sauce one that
is
91% pepper X it is pure pepper X
straight to the Dome a complete mind
body and soul takeover the hottest last
dab we have ever made take on the
experience but only if you dare and
there you have it it's another hot Ones
hot sauce Symphony call us the show pin
of chilies and as always if you'd like
to get your hands on the Season 22 hot
Ones hot sauce lineup that's
heatness.com heatness.com heatness.com
so that you can play at home in last
season we surpassed the 300 episode Mark
through pandemics through strikes
through everything hot ones must go on
and that is my promise to you Thursdays
at 11:00 a.m. brand new episodes of hot
ones a brand new season to carry us
through to the end of the year thank you
so much for watching and allowing us to
do this time and time again and as long
as you show up I'll burn my face off and
that is a hot one's promise we'll see
you soon
[Music]
hi spice Lords camera guy Bill here in
the hot one studio for Season 22 who I
don't know about you but I'm feeling
Season 22 thank you so much for watching
we really appreciate it all the way from
season 1 to 2 3 4 8 9 10 15 16 17 20 21
22 seasons can you believe it to say up
to date for all the latest and greatest
hot ones content please like And
subscribe down below and we'll we'll see
you on Season 22 wo
[Music]